[Music]
Hey guys, its Yumi here, one of the
participant of Psych2Go.
I hope all of you have been doing well, I
know I’ve been missing but now I'm back.
You know, life gets tough sometimes, we go
through up and downs but you know, and just
remember to smile and I promise you everything
will be OK.
So, I'm here to say that we have finally hit
2 million subscribers on YouTube and I'm so
thankful for each and every one of you, and
we couldn't have done it without you guys.
Psych2Go was built as a community of people
or for a community of people to come to during
their hard times, whether it's depression,
anxiety, relationship problems, whatever it
was, we built this company for people to connect
with each other, to relate and know that you're
not alone.
And I'm so happy and so thankful for each
and every single one of you and it couldn't
have been here without you guys.
So, I'm here to tell you about our great friend,
his name is Coach Bahman and he has recently
did a video on our Psych2Go magazines and
his YouTube channel is "Your Favorite Coach".
And what it is is he is a counselor and he
talks to you, it's like he's having a conversation
with you from heart to heart and he connects
with you by inner peace and positivity.
And honestly, after watching his videos, he
is now my favorite coach and he will soon
be your favorite coach too.
So, show him some love, go follow him, subscribe
to his channel on his Instagram social media,
whatever it is and just show him some love
OK?
But that's it for now and I’ll see you guys
next time, OK?
Being a parent is probably one of the most
important jobs.
Right now, there's an entire generation of
young children who will one day inherit the
earth.
Parents aren't just building a family, they're
building the future of our society.
Raising children in a healthy way should be
a huge priority for everyone.
But the sad truth is that poor parenting is
linked to 10 psychological factors.
Number one; Parents who have gone through
psychological distress are more likely to
mistreat their kids.
What happens when a parent suffers from serious
mental distress?
Some psychologists will tell you that parents
affected with psychological distress may treat
their own children with hostility and rejection.
For example, they might push their children
away after dealing with something terrible
because they just want to be left alone.
Studies have shown that when parents reject
their children, they cause all kinds of issues
in their little ones.
These issues include sleep problems and listlessness.
In this case at least, it seems like the psychological
issues that the parents are facing are projecting
and harming their children.
In effect, these children may develop psychological
issues as a result of reoccurring abuse.
Number two; Depressed parents can show a total
lack of emotion towards their kids.
Depression is a very common mental disorder,
but what happens when parents develop it?
How does it affect their children?
One 2018 study revealed that depressed parents
do not show proper sentiments or emotions
towards their children or their feelings about
parenting responsibilities are assumed negative.
To combat this, one researcher proposed a
radically different treatment approach; one
that focused on the entire family unit instead
of the individual alone.
Number three; children show less trust towards
parents with low self-esteem issues.
Low self-esteem is something most of us have
struggled with at some point.
So what happens when children see their parents
suffering from this?
One study found that low self-esteem had an
impact on the trust between parents and children.
Interesting research shows that self-esteem
radically impact our perception of our own
relationships.
When we have low self-esteem, we might believe
that our relationships are much worse than
they actually are.
Parents might believe that they have a strained
relationship with their children, when really
it's not all that bad.
Number 4; Poor parenting is linked to early
psychopathy.
A lot of YouTubers right now are talking about
sociopathy and psychopathy, and it's been
really enlightening.
Psychopathy is characterized by antisocial
and immoral behavior; issues with romantic
relationships and extreme egocentricity.
But did you know that early psychopathy can
be caused by poor parenting?
More specifically, one 2017 study stated that
harsh discipline and insensitivity could contribute
to early psychopathy and other behavioral
problems.
The consequences of this are quite severe.
Many times, parents who try to correct psychopathic
behavior at a young age end up making it worse.
A child's mind is plastic and changeable when
they are young, which means that if intervention
isn't successful during childhood, psychopathy
could end up being a permanent thing in the
future.
Number 5; Parents who have been abused as
children can result in less empathy with their
kids.
Parents raise their kids with an eye to the
past, to their own childhoods.
But what happens if these parents experienced
abuse when they were young?
One study stated that mothers with sexual
abuse history in childhood may suffer from
greater parenting stress, which can lead to
diminished empathy with their own children.
Simply put, this means that mothers who have
been abused have a hard time connecting and
bonding with their young ones.
Studies have shown that children who grow
up without a good initial bond are less likely
to be happy and resilient.
Number six; Anxiety disorder in kids is linked
to poor parenting.
Interestingly enough, poor parenting is linked
to anxiety disorder in children.
New research has found that anxiety disorder
is linked to over controlling parents who
don't give their children enough independence.
These children find it hard to control their
own behavior and achieve independence.
If you've been controlled for your whole life,
it's hard to start taking things into your
own hands.
Number seven; Irrational and uneducated beliefs
in mothers is linked with more behavioral
problems in their daughters.
Every parent wants to provide their children
with a solid rational education.
It's one of the most important tools you can
provide your child with.
So, how does education levels in parents impact
their children?
One study came to the conclusion that younger
mothers with lower levels of education are
more likely to have daughters with behavioral
problems.
Number eight; Lack of parental warmth is linked
with higher anxiety.
Different parents have different approaches
when it comes to raising their kids.
Some like to be very authoritative while others
like to be more laid-back.
But when it comes to anxiety in children,
a very important factor is how warm parents
are towards their children.
This was confirmed by a 2003 study which found
that perceived parental warmth was positively
associated with active coping and negatively
correlated with trait anxiety in adolescents.
Number nine; Authoritarian parents can cause
their kids to become depersonalized.
Depersonalization disorder is where people
feel like they're disconnected from their
own bodies and thoughts, almost like they're
watching themselves from the outside looking
in.
One study examined multiple different parenting
styles including authoritarian, permissive,
authoritative and indifferent.
Among other things, they discovered that authoritarian
parents had children which showed higher scores
on depersonalization.
Number 10; Crime filled neighborhoods are
linked to poor parenting.
First, let's examine what can cause poor parenting.
Research has shown that a parent who lives
in a bad neighborhood can be severely impacted
by their environment and this can actually
affect their children in a negative way as
well.
Simply put, this means that bad neighborhoods
can result in poor parenting.
Hey!
My name is Christian Verzosa, I did the music
and animation for this video and I'm here
to thank you guys for watching.
As some of you guys might have noticed, I
do read the comments and occasionally respond
and I couldn't help but notice how many people
out there have discovered something about
themselves through our videos.
Given the nature of the previous topic, we
felt it necessary to provide a few different
resources for anybody who might be going through
some tough times.
I'd also recommend PantslessPajamas video
on abuse for a more personal take on the subject.
Like and comment below and know that I mean
it when I say I hope things get better.
Thanks for watching!